i pipistrelli si muovono e si orientano
senza usare la vista e utilizzano una
specie di sonar che invia e riceve degli
ultrasuoni e la loro capacità di
riconoscere il mondo circostante è
talmente elevata che non è così diversa
da quella che abbiamo noi
utilizzando la vista
immaginiamo di essere un pipistrello e
di volare per questa sala probabilmente
nel nostro cervello si disegnerebbero
delle mappe sonore non tanto diverse da
delle immagini e magari non avrebbero i
colori ma le forme comparirebbero come
illuminate dal fascio di una potente
torcia elettrica per poi scomparire di
nuovo nel buio e se noi fossimo degli
esperti di pipistrelli probabilmente
saremmo in grado di capire molte cose
rispetto al mondo dei pipistrelli e
potremmo immaginarci tantissime cose in
più ma per quanto la nostra conoscenza
proprio profonda e la nostra immagine
viva
noi non saremo mai in grado di capire
che cosa vuol dire muoversi in un mondo
di ultrasuoni non saremo mai in grado di
capire che cosa vuol dire essere un
pipistrello che cosa senta un
pipistrello
questa argomentazione fu sollevata per
la prima volta nel 1974 da un filosofo
americano che si chiamava thomas nagel e
gli criticava quegli scienziati che
riducevano la coscienza all'attività
cerebrale
secondo nega anche se noi riuscissimo a
capire perfettamente come funziona il
cervello non saremo mai in grado di
spiegare la coscienza l'esperienza
oggettiva cioè quella che cerca di
spiegare nei minimi dettagli la
funzionalità cerebrale trova il suo
limite
nell esperienza soggettiva che è quella
che prova ognuno di noi quella che prova
il cervello che viene studiato guardate
questa immagine quanti di voi vedono il
viso di una vecchia potete alzare la
mano per favore ok
quanti di voi vedono invece il corpo di
una donna il viso di una vecchia naso
corpo di una donna
ok allora questa è la vecchia al naso la
bocca invece la donna è la testa cai la
piuma di un cappello i capelli il viso
questo perché anche se gli stimoli sono
simili o identici e i nostri sensi
funzionano più o meno tutti allo stesso
modo
l'elaborazione che poi avviene nel
nostro cervello è diversa è diversa per
ognuno di noi l'esperienza che abbiamo
del mondo è una cosa del tutto
soggettiva e privata e come tale rimane
inaccessibile agli altri vabbè pazienza
per fortuna possiamo continuare a
pensare male del nostro vicino di casa o
del nostro vicino di poltrona e lui non
se ne accorge ma immaginiamo invece
quando abbiamo proprio bisogno che
qualcuno riesca a capire quello che noi
stiamo vivendo che qualcuno si metta nei
nostri panni
pensiamo a quando siamo arrabbiati o
quando ci sentiamo offesi o feriti
pensiamo quando siamo felici e abbiamo
voglia di condividere la felicità
complici ha accanto pensiamo quando
andiamo dal medico e avremmo proprio
bisogno di spiegargli nei minimi
dettagli quello che noi proviamo e di
spiegargli anche e di spiegargli
perfettamente e vorremmo che lui si
mettesse nei nostri panni che capisce
perfettamente quello che noi gli stiamo
dicendo
e invece lui che non ci conosce ci ridà
un immagine di noi che magari non è
quella che siamo abituati a vedere la
medicina ha fatto grandissimi sviluppi
scientifici
negli ultimi anni la le malattie come
oggetto i meccanismi che stanno alla
base delle malattie sono ormai noti la
medicina ha sviluppato una tecnologia
formidabile per curarci e la medicina e
la la medicina quasi come formula
chimica formula matematica e la base di
qualsiasi pratica clinica quotidiana e
anche la salute ha in qualche modo è
stata sottoposta allo stesso meccanismo
di indagine
la salute viene definita come la
normalità come i parametri entro i quali
i nostri le funzioni del nostro corpo
devono rientrare
salute e malattia benessere o malessere
trovano poca poca importanza poco conto
se non sono confermati da dei dei valori
dagli esami del sangue normali dai
valori della pressione
dall'elettrocardiogramma la salute è
qualche cosa di ideale dobbiamo sempre
di più adeguarci a nudi a non l'idea ad
un ideale di uomo o donna sani che
spesso nulla hanno a che vedere con il
nostro essere uomo donna
i che non è male il colesterolo nel
sangue non può essere misurato solo
guardandoci le vene i tumori crescono
silenziosi nel nostro corpo e quando
danno segni di se a volte è troppo tardi
ma ignorare totalmente o quasi quella
che è l'esperienza soggettiva della
malattia quella che è l'esperienza che
ogni paziente fa quando si sente malato
io credo che dia origine a due grandi
problemi nel mondo sanitario di oggi il
primo problema è la
deresponsabilizzazione la
deresponsabilizzazione vuol dire che i
medici non si sentono responsabili
direttamente della cura demandano la
cura dei loro malati a degli oggetti
esterni all'antibiotico all'operazione
all'atac nulla o quasi nulla viene
lasciata a quella che è la relazione di
cura all'ascolto all'accoglienza
all'empatia e per quel che riguarda le
persone le persone non sono più
responsabili della loro salute
c'è la medicina che ci pensa se ho il
diabete
c'è la pastiglia se ho la pressione alta
c'è un'altra pastiglia
se mi viene l'infarto c'è
l'angioplastica e non importa se fumo se
mangio male se faccio poco movimento se
sono stressato quella è la cultura la
società alla globalizzazione e la
deresponsabilizzazione si porta dietro
un altro problema che è il rifiuto i
medici rifiutano e ad una malattia non
esista una medicina che possa
combatterla
si ostinano a trattare spesso corpi
molto malati con delle medicine che non
guariscono più e non possono guarire è
un po come continuare a mettere delle
toppe a un vestito strappato ma i bookie
sotto rimangono i corpi sono sempre più
ma loro malati e non guariscono i
pazienti non accettano e non guarirà è
impossibile con tutta la tecnologia che
abbiamo che non ci sia una medicina che
guarisca il mio problema
tutti vogliamo vivere per sempre
sani e felici siamo continuamente
sedotti dall'innovazione ed al progresso
e non ci accorgiamo che tutta questa
sollecitudine che la medicina utilizza
per curare le nostre malattie spesso
nasconde una povertà di umanità una
povertà di pensiero filosofico che è
stato abbandonato
più di cento anni fa quando è cominciata
la corsa allo sviluppo tecnologico
io sono un medico faccio l'anestesista e
quindi so esattamente l'importanza della
tecnologia non potrei fare nulla senza
la tecnologia ma credo che continuare a
ignorare totalmente o quasi tutta questa
parte individuale personale del vissuto
della malattia che è una parte
misteriosa oscura e inaccessibile sia in
realtà un grandissimo limite della
medicina contemporanea
allora penso che dobbiamo muoverci
dobbiamo superare questo limite e
dobbiamo farlo tutti insieme dobbiamo
farlo noi medici infermieri operatori
sanitari ma anche voi persone sane e
persone malate e dobbiamo muoverci tutti
verso l'ascolto dobbiamo rimetterci in
ascolto in ascolto di tutto ciò che
filtra attraverso i nostri sensi in
ascolto di tutto ciò che il nostro corpo
ci dice continuamente e quanto più noi
riusciamo ad essere consapevoli di noi
stessi
tanto più riusciamo a immaginarci
l'altro riusciamo a costruire una
coscienza comune che ci può aiutare
nelle difficoltà quando siamo malati o
quando abbiamo di fronte una persona
malata sentire l'altro sentire gli altri
esattamente come sentiamo noi stessi è
un po come imparare a muoversi nel buio
e disegnare delle mappe sonore proprio
come fanno i pipistrelli
ma questa volta con dei colori brillanti
di una notte stellata
[Applauso]